we start this morning with the pandemic
and a warning of dire months ahead as
the biden administration pushes to
reopen schools 83 000 people have died
just in january the deadliest month of
the pandemic so far
the cdc projects another 85 thousand
could die
in the next three weeks officials say
new covet variants have now been
detected in more than half the country
but it is believed that the vaccines
work on these mutations as well
meg oliver is in montclair new jersey
that's one of the many places where
school safety concerns
are putting in-person learning on hold
meg good morning to you
tony good morning the biden
administration is making the reopening
of schools like this
one of the central goals of its national
coronavirus response plans
it's an ambitious plan with a host of
other goals like accelerating the
distribution and administration of
coronavirus vaccines
yesterday the new team met and they
offered a blunt assessment
of the long road ahead
the problems persist at vaccination
sites nationwide
long lines cancellations and supply
shortages
and while president biden has pledged to
speed up the process
his administration's covered response
team is tempering
expectations it will be months before
everyone who wants a vaccine will be
able to get one
fema has requested up to 10 thousand
service members from the defense
department to help staff as many as 100
vaccination sites nationwide
heart of the biden administration's
covered response plan is focused on
reopening
schools with the goal of getting a
majority of k-8 schools
safely open in his first 100 days
a hundred days to get kids back in
school is not quick enough
school's closed is a national emergency
joseph allen is the director of the
healthy buildings program at the harvard
school of public health
what's the biggest obstacle schools are
facing implementing these guidelines
well i think there's a lot of distrust
and confusion
from the scientific perspective it's
really quite clear
it's really speaks a lot to how our
country has de-prioritized schools
in a recent cdc study says there's
little evidence for transmission in
schools
where precautions are met like mandatory
masks
physical distancing and improved
ventilation
but some teachers unions say school
systems do not have these covet 19
precautions in place
for a safe reopening in chicago
educators are threatening to strike if
the district does not meet
their safety demands my message to the
teachers unions
is we need you guys if you go out on
strike our future is at stake
chicago mom tamika hinton is a single
parent to ten-year-old destin
when in-person classes stopped she cut
her work hours to stay home and help her
son with virtual learning
with her finances strained the two of
them moved in
with her grandfather i've been hit
really really hard
i had to downsize a lot of different
things how long can you maintain this
not long not long
the white house plan focuses mostly on
k-8 students getting back in the
classroom they say younger kids are
their priority
because remote learning has been
particularly difficult
and getting them back in the classroom
would alleviate child care challenges
michelle relief is needed meg thank you
so much